Opposers...
I want to talk about
the most vulnerable Americans:
guns.
Everywhere you look,
enemies of the Second Amendment
are making it harder
for gun lovers
to become gun owners.
The freedom haters
at Dick's Sporting Goods
recently took a stand
against the NRA
and experienced
a small rise in sales.
Unbelievable.
You know, I try not
to think about Dick's,
-but sometimes I can't help it.
-(laughter)
It makes me confused, you know?
I'm sure the left would love it
if I just played footage
of Dick's all night, but...
there are other channels
for that.
See, I want to focus
on the people
helping to keep us armed,
so let's celebrate
our country's bravest and
loudest Guardians of the Guns.
-♪ ♪
-(yelling)
(cheering, applause)
Yes.
Our first guardian is
Kansas gubernatorial candidate,
Kris Kobach.
He's a MAGA bumper sticker
origami'd into a swan
that hates Mexicans.
Now, you remember Kobach
from his brave push
to prove the president's claim
that three to five million
people voted illegally
in the 2016 election.
Now, just because the press
will tell you Kobach
did not prove his case
on voter fraud
does not mean this hard-right
hero is done poking libs.
Kobach is now under fire
for being--
I can't believe
I'm saying this--
too patriotic at a parade.
NEWSMAN: Kansas secretary
of state Kris Kobach
firing back
at a "snowflake meltdown"
after many on the left
cried foul
over his American flag Jeep
mounted with a fake gun.
Tell me about this parade
and why you rode in the Jeep
with the gun on the side?
Yes! Love that question.
(laughter)
But to clarify,
Kobach's gun was on the top.
The side gun is for picnics.
This was a parade.
For most people, that is
the perfect parade vehicle.
In fact, the audience reaction
was overwhelmingly positive.
I've been in dozens of parades,
never had so much positive
reaction from the audience.
"So much positive reaction."
It's amazing
how much people love you
when you hold them at gunpoint.
(laughter)
One thrilled spectator
noted that...
...and that he was there
with his six-year-old daughter
who "worries constantly"
about school shootings
and...
Yeah, Kris, sounds like they
(bleep) loved it.
And who cares if you scare
a six-year-old.
She can't vote.
And by the time she can, you can
just purge her from the rolls.
So, Kris Kobach, welcome to
the Guardians of the Gun.
(gunshot)
Now, once again the left
is picking on Florida.
Just because when you give
America a good shake,
it's where all
the weird stuff ends up.
This time, they're going after
Florida agriculture commissioner
and Republican gubernatorial
hopeful Adam Putnam.
This beautiful
vitamin deficient Ron Weasley...
(laughter)
has had a target on his back
ever since he tweeted,
"I'm a proud #NRASellout."
Of course, the libs were pissed
he sold out.
They hate it
when anyone makes money.
And now the media
is coming after Putnam
for this overblown
nothing pancake.
An investigation in Florida
found that the state failed
to review concealed weapons
background checks for a year
because an employee couldn't
log into the database.
(laughing)
Log in problems?
How many times do I have
to tell you guys
the password is "Bang Bang 69"?
Write it down.
(laughter)
Like any good leader Putnam
was quick to place the blame
on a deceitful
and negligent employee.
An issue I grapple with myself
all the time, Lorraine.
(laughter)
The disgraced employee
who went directly
from working in the mail room,
to overseeing the use of the
national instant criminal
background check system,
added, "I didn't understand why
I was put in charge of it."
I've heard that one before,
Lorraine.
So, thank you, Adam Putnam,
you are a steadfast guardian
of the gun.
-(gunshot)
-(cheering and applause)
Now, look...
I know that gun violence is
a problem in America,
especially in our schools.
And I'm devoted to finding a way
to solve this problem.
But while the crazy left
is chasing after
pipe dream solutions
like fewer guns,
realists like me and defense
specialist Allison Barrie
at Fox News, are focused on more
reality-based solutions.
Here's the scenario:
We've got children barricaded
into classrooms.
What if we were able to just
roll up this cannon,
punch holes-- escape holes,
man-sized escape holes--
into those walls safely,
so that children aren't hurt
by that blast,
and that the children escape
directly out of the classrooms.
Finally someone's talking sense!
Ah! Ah!
(applause)
Next time there's an active
shooter incident,
all we have to do
is line up this cannon
and methodically blow holes
in every exterior classroom wall
in the building.
This is exactly the kind of
"more gun" solution
I was waiting for.
And I got to be honest,
it sounds like a lot of fun.
BARRIE: Now I know it sounds
like a lot of fun.
It gets better.
What does it use for ammo?
It has unique ammo.
It uses water bottles
as powerful missiles.
Once loaded into this cannon,
they can punch through walls,
two layer walls, brick walls,
rip through metal,
rip through vehicles,
just using water bottles
as ammunition.
Yes, weaponizing water.
It's what Jesus would do
if he wasn't such a pussy.
(laughter and applause)
This... this is the kind of
thinking we need in America.
What about cannons in every
classroom designed
to launch kids through the roof
at the first sign of danger?
What about an entire school
that is a cannon?
That's how we take education
to new heights.
So, water cannon, welcome to
the Guardians of the Gun.
-(gunshot)
-Now...
Stay locked and loaded,
Opposers,
and remember,
it's "Bang Bang 69."
Also, Lorraine, you're fired.